-Normally I bring out
my whole family together,
but this year I am going
to start with my dad.
All the way from his home
in New Hampshire
and his fresh
positive COVID test,
please welcome Larry Meyers,
everybody!
Give it up for Larry!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi.
-How are you?
Now, I know you do not
have any symptoms.
Are you still feeling okay?
-Yeah, it's kind of like being
busted, disgusted, and untrusted
when you -- when you get
a positive COVID test.
But there's two
good things about it.
Three, I guess.
The first is that
I don't have any symptoms,
and the second is that
I did test negative today.
So I'm gonna be catching up
with you guys over the weekend.
And the most important
is that even though
this is like you being in
the attic when you did the show,
I don't have to look
at the sea captain.
-Yeah, that's true.
You've always been
very anti sea captain.
Let's bring some of the
sea captain's supporters out.
My mom, Hilary Meyers,
and my brother, Josh Meyers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright. So, first of all,
cheers, everybody.
-Oh, cheers.
-DO you have your drinks?
-Oh, I got a drink right here.
-There you go.
Cheers. Lovely to
be with you guys.
Happy Thanksgiving.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-And, Mom, be honest.
When Dad said
he tested positive,
did you think about staying at
home in New Hampshire with him?
-Uh...no.
[ Laughter ]
-Dad, were you surprised
how quickly she left?
-Oh, no, not at all.
Actually, any time that I get
a little bit under the weather,
the first thing I do
is hide the car keys,
because I'm always worried
that she'll put me in a home.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very --
That's very wise.
Now, I don't know
about you, Josh,
but, you know, when I heard
Dad tested positive,
that meant that Mom
was going to come here
and get three days
with just us in the city.
And when I realized what
she was getting out of this,
were you worried like I was
that maybe she had poisoned Dad?
-She's had so many opportunities
to poison him.
If she has,
he just is resilient.
-Yeah. Oh, this might be
a situation
where she has been poisoning him
for years and years,
but he's just built up...
-An immunity to it. Yeah.
-Oh, that would be nice.
That'd be a nice family story.
Now, of course,
you're not alone, Dad.
You're with your Sheepdog,
Albert.
Is Albert good company?
-He's very good company.
He happens to be outside
right now,
even though it's dark.
He's so popular and friendly
that everybody that comes up --
We live on the top of a hill,
on a cul-de-sac.
But every UPS man,
garbage man, FedEx guy,
everybody that walks up
the hill,
every child that lives
on the street
has to stop and play with him
and spend some time with them.
So even the fact
that some people
might walk at night
with their dogs,
he's out there waiting
for them right now.
-That's really --
Now, Mom, you shared with us
recently your concern
about how much Dad
is talking to Albert.
-Well, it's beyond.
-So what's a normal conversation
that you'll hear
between Dad and the dog?
-"I love you more than anything.
You're the sweetest --
the sweetest thing
I've ever met."
He'll be saying this --
-Within earshot?
-Are you within earshot?
-I'm laying right next to him
in bed!
And I reach over.
I think he's talking to me.
And I feel Albert's head.
-That must be very jarring.
-It is jarring!
It is jarring.
-Now, Josh, you are leaving
tomorrow morning
to go back to LA to see --
to celebrate
with your girlfriend, Mackenzie,
and your dog, Debbie.
-Yeah.
-Now, Debbie is not
a purebred dog.
-She's not, no.
-But she's very photogenic.
-Yeah.
-Now, where did you
come across Debbie?
-We found her on the street.
-So she's a rescue.
And not a rescue
you got at a shelter.
You were the actual rescuer
in this case.
-Yes. Yeah. We found her.
Yeah, found her on the street.
-And they both dress up
very well.
Here is -- He's Mackenzie
and Debbie, who are --
-A couple beauties.
-Couple of beauties right there.
Very lucky
to have you coming home.
We had a very nice trip
this summer.
In August, we went
and saw our alma mater,
Northwestern,
play in Dublin, Ireland,
and we went to a football game
at a beautiful, I should say,
Irish stadium.
But then something
happened, Dad,
that was -- It was as if Mom
wished it to happen.
-Oh.
-Yeah, this was
really something.
There were 43,000 people there,
and it was a no-cash stadium.
So you only could pay for beer
or food with a credit card.
And 43,000 people were there
for this event.
And the credit-card processor
goes down.
So they had no way to accept
any credit-card payments.
So they gave everybody
free beer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I should note, here's
a photo you took of mom.
And, Josh, what do you
call this technique
that she's doing there?
-That is double fisting.
Double fisting. She was offered
a beer and she's like,
"Yeah, I'll take one,"
and it was like,
Well, you still have a beer."
She's like,
"Yeah, I'll take one."
-I also should note,
looking at this photo,
this is a very good way
for me to pose my chin.
I think. I should do that --
I should do that
for my next round of headshots.
Now, Josh, is it rare for you
to see your mother
double fisting?
Have you ever seen it since?
-Well, funny you should
mention that.
As we arrived,
there was a soccer game,
the US's first soccer game
in the World Cup,
and we had some friends
who were at a bar,
and it was an open bar,
so I told Mom,
"Do you want to just come
straight from the airport
and meet me there?"
And she was like, "Yes, I will."
And she got a gin and tonic.
And then there was a nice guy
who's like,
"I'm going to the bar.
Can I get you something?"
She still had
half a gin and tonic,
but she was like,
"I'll take a gin and tonic."
There wasn't a long line
at the bar,
and he came right back,
and I was like,
"Do you want me to put
one of those down for you?"
And she said, "No, I'm good."
So this is just from --
That's from Monday.
Double fisting again.
-Yeah.
-This is.
-Hey. Now, wait a minute.
This is an open bar.
-Okay.
-I think that explains it.
-Nobody worries that
you're bad with money.
No one's sitting here
going like,
"Could she afford
two gin and tonics?"
You're missing
the whole point here.
-When they're free, I take them.
-Yeah, well, yeah. There you go.
In this economy, you gotta.
-You gotta.
-I will say my favorite --
One of the wonderful things
about being in Dublin
was how charming
our many taxi drivers were.
And, now, Mom,
would you agree that maybe
one of the knocks on you
over the years
is that you ask
a lot of questions?
-Uh, yeah.
-Yeah.
That's a thing
that you've been told a lot
by the men in your life,
is you ask a lot of questions.
And, you know,
we love our mom very much,
and so we try not to be
too harsh about the fact
that maybe the incessant
questions are a little tiring.
But we got into a taxi
in Dublin,
and you slid into the backseat
and you said very loud,
loud enough for the cab driver
to hear, obviously.
You said,
"I have a lot of questions
about what we're doing today!"
And our Dublin cab driver --
This is within 5 seconds
of meeting my mom --
said, "I'm gonna tell you
what you're gonna do today.
Step one, I'm gonna
drop you off at a pub.
Step two, you're gonna stop
asking so many "fecking"
questions.
[ Laughter ]
He was like an Irish angel.
-Yeah. Shut her down.
-He shut her down with that.
You gave him a big laugh.
-I did. I did.
-Suddenly he clocked that you
would be the kind of person
would enjoy a burn like that.
-Yes. Yes.
-Now, Dad,
I know you and Josh golfed
a fair amount in Ireland.
And I know you have a story,
a golf story.
-I've got an Irish golf story.
-Yeah.
-Well, yeah,
I -- I definitely --
I have a lot of golf stories,
first of all.
And I think that one
of the best golf stories I had
was that when we were
in Ireland,
I had never seen
a golf course before
because every time
I went there for business,
I was always in the city.
[ No dialogue ]
-What happened?
What'd you do?
-I muted him.
-What?!
-Yeah.
-I can't hear this story again.
I've heard it 50 times!
-You're not allowed to mute Dad!
[ Applause ]
-I'm sorry. 52 years.
I've had enough.
-I mean, he's having
a really good time telling it.
-He really is.
-Now, don't -- You guys
have heard this one.
-I don't know.
It's kind of more fun
when you just hear his face.
[ Laughter ]
-This is story number 41
on my list.
-You know what?
Why don't we let him wrap it up?
We'll take a commercial.
We'll be right back with more
from the Meyers family.